what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about quasars quasars and
that it's a short form for quasi-stellar
quasi-stellar radio sources radio
sources and this name is just a
byproduct of the first observations of
quasars because all they look like were
these kind of point-like sources of
electromagnetic radiation mainly in the
radio part of the spectrum so that's
what we call them quasi-stellar radio
sources now it turns out that they are
neither stars or even quasi stellar and
they're actually not even that their
main energy isn't even being released in
the radio frequency in the radio band of
the electromagnetic spectrum they're far
more energetic than that what they
really are what they really are the
active nucleuses of galaxies so let's
think about that a little bit so if we
have a supermassive black hole at the
center of a galaxy so let me draw that
right over here so that's our
supermassive black hole maybe that's the
surface of the event horizon of the
supermassive black hole the actual mass
of the black hole is in the center of
that event horizon if there's material
that's falling that's passing by this
black hole it's going to get attracted
to it and it's going to form an
accretion disk around it this material
is going to start rotating around this
black hole and some of it if it doesn't
have enough of velocity is going to
actually fall into the black hole so you
have all of this material all of this
material going around the black hole and
some of it if it doesn't have enough
angular velocity not enough not enough
to orbit around the black hole it's
actually going to fall in now while
things let me label this this is the
accretion disk accretion accretion disk
so as things are getting are getting
faster and faster as they fall closer
and closer this black hole and bumping
into each other more and more that
gravitational potential energy from
things falling into it is to being
turned into actual energy actual
temperature and so you what you have is
things start to get really unbelievably
unbelievably hot near the surface near
the surface they get hotter and hotter
as they
closer and closer to that event horizon
and so near the event horizon itself
things are so intense that they're
actually releasing electromagnetic
they're actually releasing high
frequency electromagnetic radiation
mainly in the X in the x-ray part of the
spectrum now I want to be very clear so
there's two things here one is when you
watch when you learn about quasars or
you when I first was exposed to quasars
in like a nova special you you they make
you think that the quasar that the
radiation is somehow being released by
the black hole itself and I want to be
and I would scratch my head because I
was just told that nothing can escape
the event horizon of a black hole
including electromagnetic radiation so
how could that be being emitted by the
black hole and the answer is it's not
being emitted by the black hole it's
being emitted by the matter in the
accretion disk that hasn't quite gotten
to the event horizon yet once it's
inside of the event horizon it can no
longer any electromagnetic radiation
that it might emit will not be able to
escape the black hole anymore will not
be able to escape the actual event
horizon so all of this is from the
accretion disk around around the super
around the supermassive black hole and
the other question that used to pop in
my mind is why is it kind of come out at
these why does it come out at these kind
of perpendicular orthogonal to the plane
the plane of the actual accretion disk
and they're just you know at least my
logic tells me well things aren't going
to pop out and they're not going to pop
out along the direction of the accretion
disk because then they're going to be
absorbed by other things in fact that's
what's going to cause other things to
get heated up closer to closer to the
actual event horizon so any energy
that's going out in that direction is
just going to be absorbed and make other
things hotter and only when you go
roughly perpendicular to the plane of
the accretion disk is that energy
allowed to kind of go and transmit
freely into space now I want to be very
clear quasars are the most that these
these are the most luminous things that
we know of in the in the universe so
most most most luminous things that we
know of in the universe the the
brightest or
many quasars are on the order of
trillion Suns in luminosity so they can
be brighter than an entire galaxy and
that's just coming from material around
a fairly small region of space much
smaller much much much smaller than an
actual galaxy it's a very centers it's
kind of just the galactic core now
another interesting thing about quasars
and this kind of gives credence to this
notion of a constantly changing universe
and even to some degree the Big Bang
itself is you have these supermassive
black holes that may be formed shortly
after the Big Bang now you could imagine
at an early stage in the universe's
development there would been a lot of
mass that didn't have that would have
been near these black holes that didn't
have quite the velocities to be able to
escape them or be able to orbit around
them and so these would actually start
falling into the black hole and then
over time all of the mass that had to
fall into the black hole into the
supermassive black hole will have fallen
into the supermassive black hole and if
you imagine some future period of time
you should still have the supermassive
black hole but all you should see is
mostly things orbiting around it
anything that had to fall into it would
have already fallen into it so you
you're just going to see things orbiting
around it and this is actually what we
see if we look around us we look at our
Milky Way galaxy we don't observe a lot
of things falling and we for example the
Milky Way galaxy does does not have a
does not does not have an active nucleus
an active core it is not it is not
currently a quasar the center of the
Milky Way galaxy the supermassive black
hole there is not I guess we could say
digesting is not digesting or consuming
material but you could imagine at some
point in the Milky Way's past there
might have been a lot of material that
didn't have quite the velocity to be
able to orbit and so that was consumed
and as it would was consumed it would
emit it would emit all of this x-ray
radiation and could be observed as a
quasar and that's actually what we
observe the closest quasars and we've
observed more than 200,000 quasars the
closest quasars are on the order of 780
million million light years away
light-years away so what does that mean
we don't observe quasars closer
700 million light years so what that
tells us is is at least in our region of
the universe the most recent quasars
were 700 million 780 million years in
the past when we look at closer parts of
the universe so I mean let me draw let's
say this is the observable universe this
is us so we only start to observe
quasars at a certain distance away from
us and that distance is actually also a
certain time in the past because it took
the light 780 million years to get to us
and actually most of the quasars are
more than three billion light years away
which tells us that they only existed
more than 3 billion years in the past at
the at a younger stage of the actual
universe when there was actual material
for these supermassive black holes to
consume at the center of galaxies you
move closer in time to us and most of
that material has actually been consumed
and that's why and we just have material
orbiting around these supermassive black
holes which we call galaxies and so we
don't observe quasars anymore and just
to give an idea I mean you know these
are as we everything we learn in
cosmology there's kind of these
mind-bending concepts unbelievable
distances unbelievable masses
unbelievable brightnesses I guess you
could think about it but just to give a
sense the brightest quasars the
brightest known quasars devour on the
order of 1,000 1,000 solar masses per
year so that's on the order of 10
Earth's 10 earths per second if I did my
math right 10 Earth's 10 Earth's 4
second are being devoured by the
brightest quasars and it's that energy
of that mass that's creating around it
that's generating that's generating all
of that energy and actually I should say
I shouldn't even talk about in the
present tense these brightest quasars
this happened in the past we're just
observing it now they're know as far all
we know the rest of the universe looks
fairly similar the way our universe does
and so there really aren't that many
quasars around although the other side
of the coin might be even though most of
the material has already been consumed
maybe even by our own supermassive black
call in the center of the Milky Way at
some point in the future maybe it will
be able to consume on some more stellar
material some more a well any type of
material in the future and that might
happen about four or five billion years
in the future when we actually collide
with the Andromeda galaxy so anyway
hopefully that gave you some food for
thought